okay I've even [ __ ] started Tyler
let's get talking Syria inbox zero Seth
I'm going to record every intro to Gary
be 365 let's [ __ ] go Colin 11
articles right now let's go I wait for
every [ __ ] question you ask being
Gary Vee up in the office - rabbit
rabbit wool Victor corporation talked
about ownership and leverage 1800
sectors that out there beverage
my rant about the too many people are
meeting it's only 54 emails to the whole
company and it was great huge
communication thing about speed and
efficiency was only realizing the sink
was broken what was wrong was the well
it's not that there's too many people in
the meeting it's that there's too many
people I've got to really fix this and
smartly I've got to like fix the plane
while I'm flying it we don't tell people
leave good reviews on Glassdoor like
when things that nature is I don't want
to force anything but if you believe
what you're telling me here and
especially if you get to know me a
little bit better
I need offense on the floor because
negative in society negativities on
offense positivity zombies right here
hey how are you oh yeah it is our belief
that your social video production team
in my opinion is to people somebody
who's the ship a predator who can shoot
and edit a predators and shoot and edit
and she and he he and he she and she can
decide like divide and conquer work
together but both I'm sick good I can
both you know both you both the end to
good man you play some music or
something freaking me out
hey Emma oh yeah really that's
devastating so is hat Alexis a Gary
Vaynerchuk I couldn't find the content
matching Gary Vaynerchuk
I just want to take a good Vaynerchuk
thought into that okay watch this hey
Siri call AJ Vaynerchuk calling edge
Vader ugh he already calls our last name
Boehner Kaka
good job Alexa Alexa play I'm still
standing by Elton John I'm still
standing even concluded with crime
didn't available the Amazon Music
Unlimited would you like to learn more
yes Parmesan music unlimited lets you
play tens of millions of songs on this
device it's free for 30 days and then
you will be automatically charged three
dollars and 99 cents a month cancel
anytime terms in the Alexa yes should I
start your free trial and play I'm still
standing yes how dangerous or that you
now have Amazon music unlimited on this
design I'm still standing I wonder who's
your credit card system
so let miss Daly be even though we won't
be pushing it for a couple of weeks the
early people can get access and if they
have an Alexa and all they have to say
is Alexa download Gary 365 Alexa add
Gary Alexa add Gary B 365 to my flash
briefing oh I can do a really cool thing
Instagram you guys are getting the scoop
gary vee 365 add it to your flash
briefings hit me up if you did
especially on Twitter and then I'll
actually see it DMS are busy movie that
was all we get audio injures each one so
figure out what it looks like for work
let me get a video version this weather
actually well the video versions we
should use the the search engine because
they'll be so [ __ ] easy yeah like we
should just keyword stuff find that
exact moment and use askgaryvee the
audience they that's a big game violin
plays like it's actually going to hear
the audio from this video yeah thank you
guys
[Music]
hey guys I guess most of this episode
will probably be tonight's jam session
but uh while I've got you here
huge arbitrage holiday week are the best
I've literally met with some of the most
senior people I'm trying to do and doing
business with today and it's such an
insight right like like and then by the
way I think people should because I
always keep some mistake in my what I'm
saying I love and think many people
should take the rest of this week off
and maximize family time vacation time
reset time however it's intriguing that
there's such an opportunity to meet and
have the meetings I had today in a
three-day week where a lot of people
took off so if you're going to work
during and around Labor Day fourth of
July Memorial Day Thanksgiving Christmas
New Year's keep in mind some of the most
difficult people to get a hold of are
most available during this coming year
so that's their little tidbit I want to
give you more actionable advice when you
dream up of having a meeting with 10
people that are impossible to get a hold
of right it's the holiday weeks
ironically that are sneaky ninety-nine
out of a hundred times they are also
away with their family she's away with
her her family he's away with his family
but it's the one in the hundred and I
think the I think the the one in a
hundred is better than the one in the
thousand that you get in all the other
forty-four normal weeks of the year is
focused in Kassel yeah people like this
is the time to get somebody like because
because you know it's know we're working
like I am these three days you wanna do
think you know one just like sit around
and uh and you're right people get you
know even though other people wanted to
do it today
maybe they decide to extend them maybe
they got drunk on the 4th of July or
like mmm
work actually anymore you know it's an
incessant interesting insight that I bet
I bet you that's one of those classics I
didn't think about that kind of thing
I guarantee for people watching daily be
will get a meeting in the next year
around the holiday week because of that
tidbit is it really why do the blog this
little thing right now
I don't think you're so good of that
chicken oh I didn't even think that but
even you're the genius in the world yes
the Iraq you did what do you feel sad
that you're not in this vlog on Vienna
tonight should you want to show
everybody your awesome tan you know
beautiful you look great what's up yes I
would definitely see confidant Helen I'm
in a year when did he get your job there
just Tyler approved because I'm just go
get out of here Oh Tyler's the boss
Suriname I said yes to everything yep
can we do tonight yeah well what's next
when she here she's on her way upstairs
okay good yeah you did what did you do
Colin what you did all Gaspar summer
right you read in the video that always
oh did I yeah right some are seen work
uh Collin Collin Collin Elliot who's in
here Collin and Elliot move in together
Colin's
Colin Colin don't ecozy we're not just
have one things they never trust Iran
close enough can we stepped off that
note there why not because they can drop
a feature tomorrow
that changes whoopsy correct
all of a sudden you can actually do what
Instagram stories does and if you have
audience there Plus everybody under 25
but more specifically under 21 still
favors it and if I go right now
to the App Store which I had I didn't do
this morning which is unusual but if I
go right now
and I'm just going to look at the top of
the charts and here they are snapchat is
number 4 it's not like it's number 54
yes not dying like this thought of
deleting a platform that hundreds of
millions of people use that could start
different features in the same way that
Instagram didn't have those features and
everybody was going to snapchat
yeah why couldn't snapchat create
something tomorrow that changes the
outcome it makes zero sense in a world
where your job and your life is
predicated on you arbitrage and
attention and awareness to the things
you do to close a channel that isn't
charging you because it seems similar to
another channel would be the same thing
as saying you're not going to air it on
CNBC and Fox Business because they're
both CNBC and Fox Business or MSNBC MCS
if MSNBC and CNN both wanted you to do a
five-minute spot talk about the same
exact thing intuitively I feel like you
would do them both the only thing that
matters is attention that's where you're
trading on the only thing that matters
is other people's attention because
without it it doesn't matter what you're
creating right yeah that's why you don't
delete snapchat that's why you get good
at things that's like Alexa play my
daily briefs
here's your flower evening
from garyvee 365 am i watching the
patterns for community members who that
exists
the Lexus tops that exist because I know
that's the next landscape of attention
and so I already know that voice is the
next social media and that's why I have
a top 100 podcast and that's why I have
an Alexa flash already awesome thank you
you're welcome so much continued success
guys how you been
real well yeah life is good good to see
you again you enjoyed it last time for
the guys love it
everybody does everybody like he's cool
different respected everything yeah yeah
good they felt the authenticity yeah
definitely you know you really care yeah
yeah cool let's work with Tyler and get
together this summer before it's over
with you and your crew and I'll break it
down for you guys good my man yeah my
masters did it
continued success man get healthy I'll
see you soon hi well he's got a crew I
go to me with I know summers tight
either somewhere in me on this summer
I'm coming in for one day I've been
thinking about or right as we get back
after Labor Day
right like let's fill up our Instagram
so people are swiping up and you're
getting I'm getting instinct like in my
veins to win URL link and my Instagram
story swipe ups are driving more of the
things that I want to happen and like it
then like email and like [ __ ]
Facebook which were like my drivers
it changes real [ __ ] fast Alexa play
I'm still standing by Elton John I mean
the world can change really quick I'm
sandy
finances oh by the way miss Alexa thing
has added enormous amounts of quality to
my ability to have meetings I was
literally just like I'm just gonna do
this for fun like I'm so I posted this I
took this photo in my backyard just like
just to confuse the [ __ ] out of
everybody at work I'm going to destroy
today destroys a slang term for leaving
all my efforts on the field today field
is a slang term for my work
Alexa who's Rick Ross even 7 / Christian
soft rock artist what are we doing
there's no mega Rick Ross's we probably
had the single most productive meeting
in a history of our business
relationship and you're complaining I'm
even [ __ ] started Tyler let's get
talking Syria inbox zero
fest I'm going to record every intro to
Gary be 365 let's [ __ ] go Colin 11
articles right now
let's go I will answer every [ __ ]
question you ask
Alexis who's Ryan Harwin homie Brian and
I are going to be best friends
it's the most foregone conclusion I just
want everybody know this this is fun
just remember I said it Kobe Bryant and
I will be best friends within the next
five years best friends not just
business acquaintances homies Alexa
who's Kobe Bryant begging drive is an
American retired professional basketball
player and businessman you hear that
last thing Talia you're not yeah you
know a better businessman me and I've
got the competitive edge now
Kobe then selling candy akan kids at
school instead something going so well
just learning a lot plugging away on a
YouTube channel for Sid gaining insight
morning gathering things on today what
not but watching your content I see how
far and you are starting here I respect
that right but I think you know it's
it's macro patience micro speed it's
very hard but that's why good things
happen to me right like absolutely not
like everything that's good is hard you
know what I mean like like nothing
nobody's winning you're not winning cuz
you're winning cuz you did something
nobody else is willing to do good day
good day 10 p.m. holiday we can look at
the team anybody want to get destroyed
real quick oh no Gary
oh good job Gary
it doesn't shock he's pretty good
actually I'm the greatest of all time
you just how lucky you are there so any
- there's nothing charming son of my
move Chesson where you going 71 was
close just where you going 71 was good I
was a good try by you seven ones not bad
bro he's got to walk that one off now
that was devastating for him you walked
into a buzzsaw you walked right into a
bus he wasn't go buzzsaw right you know
what it is you know what hurts him the
most is he's been trying and prepping
and practicing I've been I've been
working and hustling and doing my thing
I just nonchalantly walk in here and
dismantled him seven to one Colin you
know what's sad it was over before it
started it was pre nothing before Justin
even got settled in T rock and B rockety
good
you rock your back here six to one you
only four shots on goal you two left
shots and goals and I goals Tyler I feel
amazing
you know it's really interesting right
like when you're just better than other
human beings and everything feels really
good
probably myself nobody who watches my
blog can beat me in bubble hockey nobody
see ya
[Music]
[Music]